The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality,
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
NANCY LYNCH: OK so today, you're
going to see something new.
In fact all this
week, you're going
to see something that's quite
different from what you've
been studying in this course.
These are algorithms.
But they're for a completely
different sort of model.
Distributed algorithms,
OK, so what are they?
So now instead of
having algorithms
that run on a typical
computer, you're
going to have algorithms that
run on a network of processors.
Or it could be on
one machine that
has multiple processors,
multi processors that memory.
Much of computing is
distributed algorithms now.
They solve problems
like communication
on the internet, data
management over a network,
allocating resources
in a network setting,
synchronizing,
reaching agreement
among different agents
at remote locations.
So these are all distributed
problems, not things
that you just solve
on one computer.
The kinds of algorithms you
design for these settings
have to work under extremely
difficult platforms
because what you have is
concurrent activity that's
going on at many locations,
many processors doing things
at the same time.
And you don't know exactly
when everybody's going
to perform their activities.
You can have different
sorts of timing uncertainty.
The order of events isn't clear.
There could be inputs that
arrive at different locations.
And then you also have to
deal with failure and recovery
of some of the processors or
some of the channels involved
in the computation.
You don't think of
any of this when
you're just trying to run an
algorithm on one computer.
So distributed algorithms
can be pretty complicated.
It's not easy to design them.
And after you design
them, you still
have to make sure
they're correct.
So there are issues involved
in proving them correct
and analyzing them.
A little bit of
history, the field
pretty much started
around the late '60s.
Edsger Dijkstra was one of the
earliest leaders in the field.
He won of the first
Turing Awards.
Leslie Lamport won the
Turing Award last year.
Although he actually
started as a very young guy,
way back in the early
days of the field.
If you want to look at some
sources, I have a book.
There's another textbook
by Attiya and Welch.
There's a new series of
monographs that basically
try to summarize many of the
important research topics
in distributed computing theory.
And the last two lines have a
couple of the main conferences
in the field.
OK so I can't do that
much in one week.
What I'll do is just
introduce the area,
by showing you two common
models for distributed networks.
And just introduce a very
few fundamental algorithms,
and you'll see along the way
some techniques for modeling
and analyzing them.
OK the two models here are
synchronous distributed
networks, and asynchronous
distributed networks.
The problems I'll look at
in the synchronous setting
are a simple problem of leader
election, which is a symmetry
breaking problem, basically.
Maximal independence set
problem, and then a couple
of problems that should
look familiar to you
from the settings of this
class, establishing structures
like breadth-first spanning
trees and shortest paths trees.
In the asynchronous case
I'll revisit these last two
problems, setting up
breadth-first and shortest path
trees.
OK so I mentioned
something about modeling
in proofs and analysis.
Turns out, getting the
formal models right
and getting real
proofs tends to be
pretty important for
distributed algorithms
because with all the stuff
going on, they're complicated.
And it's easy to make mistakes.
The kinds of models that we use
are interacting state machines,
inputs and outputs.
They send each other messages.
But the kinds of
proofs you do typically
use invariants, a
technique that you're very
familiar with from this class.
You can still use them
in a distributed setting.
And you still prove them
the same way, by induction.
Something else that comes up a
lot in the distributed setting
is modeling and proofs
using levels of abstraction.
You might want to give
an abstract description
of an algorithm and
prove that that works.
And then you have a very
detailed, complicated,
lower level description that you
can prove implements the higher
level description.
That's another
popular technique.
You use different kinds
of complexity measures.
For time complexity,
you would measure rounds
if it's the synchronous
model, or some approximation
to real time, if it's
the asynchronous model.
You also count communication,
either the number
of messages you send, or
the total number of bits
that you send in an algorithm.
So throughout
these two lectures,
we'll be looking at
distributed networks.
So you start with a graph.
Let's just look at
undirected graphs this week.
We use n in this
field for what you're
calling v, the total number
of nodes in the network
or vertices in the graph.
We use the notation gamma of
u to mean the neighbors of u
in the graph.
So every vertex of the graph has
a set of immediate neighboring
vertices.
That's gamma of u.
And the degree of u is the size
of the neighborhood, the number
of neighbors of the vertex.
OK so we start with the graph.
But now we're
going to plunk down
a process, some kind
of active entity
at each vertex of the graph.
So this is some
kind of automaton.
If you've taken automata
theory, it's not really
finite state machines, it's more
like infinite state automata
that can interact
with each other.
So we usually talk about
vertices in a graph, processes
at the vertices of a graph.
But sometimes we get
sloppy and just say nodes.
And we could mean either the
vertex or the active thing
running at the vertex.
Can't keep them
straight all the time.
OK and then with the
edges of the graph,
we would put
communication channels,
one in each direction,
so that the processes
can communicate over the edges.
This week I'm not going
to talk about what
happens when you introduce
failures because we just
don't have time.
A lot of distributed computing
theory deals with what
happens when some of the
components in your system fail.
How do you cope with that?
So we'll start right in
with synchronous distributed
algorithms.
A source for that,
if you're interested
is the first technical
chapter in my book.
OK so you have processes
at the nodes of a graph,
like I just said.
They communicate using messages.
So think of each process as not
knowing who his neighbors are,
not knowing anything
about the graph.
So what do they have?
They have ports.
You could say they have output
ports, on which they could send
a message, and then some
input ports on which messages
can come in.
So in general, the
process doesn't know
who the ports are connected to.
It just has local
names for the ports,
like one, two, three,
up to the degree.
If you have any questions
just stop me and ask,
if something's not clear.
Otherwise I'll go pretty fast.
And I know that none
of this is familiar.
So in general, the
processes don't have
to be distinguishable at all.
So they don't have to have
special unique identifiers
so you could tell
the processes apart.
They could be
completely identical.
Well if they have
different numbers of ports,
they're not exactly identical.
They certainly
know how many ports
they have, and release the
local names for the ports.
Good so these are
processes sitting
at the nodes of the graph.
What do they do?
So they execute.
And we talk about an
execution of this network.
It goes in synchronous
rounds, and every round,
every process
looks at its state,
and decides what
messages it's going
to send on all of the ports.
So it could send different
messages on different ports.
So then what happens
is all the messages
that the processes decide to
send get put onto the channels
and they get delivered to
the process at the other end.
So the process of the
other end is in some state.
All these messages come in.
It updates its state, based
on the arriving messages.
So it changes state in
response to whatever comes in.
And this is completely different
from this semester so far.
We're going to completely
ignore the costs
of the local computation.
So each node can compute
some complicated algorithm
of the sort you've been
studying in this class,
and we usually don't
consider that cost.
We're more worried about
the communication costs.
And so we'll be focusing on the
number of rounds that it takes,
in the synchronous case, and
the number of communication
messages or bits.
OK so far?
So let's start on
the first problem.
Here's a graph.
The nodes start out
possibly identical,
but you want to somehow
distinguish one of them
to be a leader.
So you have this arbitrary,
connected, undirected graph.
And exactly one
process is supposed
to elect itself the leader.
That means it outputs a
special leader signal.
so exactly one should do that.
So why do you want a leader?
Well in practice, leaders
can coordinate things.
They can take charge
of communication,
and inform other
nodes when they're
allowed to send messages.
They can coordinate
the processing of data.
Basically it allows
you to centralize
some of the computation.
It can schedule the
other processes.
It can allocate the resources.
It could help to reach
agreement among the processes,
if they start out with
different opinions about what
is supposed to happen.
All right so let's start
out with a very simple case.
You have a clique.
Here's a four clique, where
all the vertices are directly
connected to all
the other vertices,
with two directional channels.
And the processes are identical.
So I should have
asked you, instead
of just giving the
answer here, but are they
able to elect a leader?
So this theorem says that in
general, that's impossible.
Or it's not possible, in
the most general case.
If you have, no
matter what n is,
let's just say we have an
n vertex clique for some n.
It's not possible to have
any algorithm that you
can have all the processes
run, if it's deterministic
and the processes start
out all indistinguishable.
There's no way
that they can elect
a single node as a leader.
So do you have an intuition
for why that might be the case?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're
all connected, and
the cross-problem
communication in one round
is equal, then to
be equal likely
to select each one of them.
It would be--
NANCY LYNCH: It's deterministic
there's no likelihood here.
And nobody is doing
any selecting.
You're talking as if there's
somebody who's choosing
a process to do something.
There isn't anyone in charge.
So this is a really
different way of thinking.
AUDIENCE: So every node is
essentially the exact same.
So if it says, OK, let's
assume I'm going to be leader,
everyone is going to assume
they're going to be leader.
NANCY LYNCH: That's exactly
the right intuition.
They can't
distinguish themselves
because they're always
going to do the same thing.
Let's look at a
very simple case.
Suppose we have just two nodes,
two node clique, two nodes
connected by channels.
These are identical.
They're deterministic.
What can they do?
Well you could try to design
algorithms for one of them
to elect itself as the leader.
But you can show,
by using induction,
that the processes
are actually going
to remain in the same state
as each other forever,
however many rounds you execute.
So let's slow down.
We can work by contradiction.
Suppose you have an algorithm
that solves this problem.
Both of the processes,
they're identical.
They start in the
same start state.
Let's say there's a
unique start state.
So we could prove by induction
on the number of rounds
that after any number
of rounds, say r rounds,
the processes are still
in identical states.
So the inductive step
is, all right, they're
in identical states after
some number of rounds.
Let's look at the next round.
They're in the same state.
So they generate
the same messages.
So they each other
They receive the same message.
And then they make
the same state change.
So they stay in the same state.
And you can tweak
this, and say how this
works for-- yeah, question?
AUDIENCE: So in what ways is
the proof a contradiction?
NANCY LYNCH: I'm not finished.
You're exactly right.
We have to finish by using the
requirements of the problem.
Since the algorithm has to solve
the leader election problem,
the requirements say that
eventually, one of them
has to output leader.
And what happens when he does?
Anyone?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: You have node also
outputting the leader signal.
NANCY LYNCH: Yeah the other one
would also do the same thing.
We're saying round by round,
they stay in the same state.
So as someone said before,
when one guy outputs leader,
at the same round the other
guy will output leader as well.
So that's a contradiction
to the problem requirements.
Notice we didn't
assume anything at all
about exactly how
the algorithm works.
We're just saying, however it
works, it can't solve this,
under the assumptions
that the nodes
are indistinguishable
and deterministic.
So as you can see,
this will extend if you
have larger cliques of size n.
So now the process has
not just one output port,
it has n minus 1 output ports to
connect to all the other nodes.
Let's say they're numbered
1 through n minus 1.
And one of the possibilities,
and one I'll use in this proof
is that the ports happen to
be numbered consistently.
So that if you have output
port number k at one node,
it's connected to input port
number k at the other end.
So that's one way
things can match up.
All right if that's
the case, we could
do the same proof we just did.
Show by induction that all
the processes in the clique
remain in the same
state forever.
So same proof.
Suppose you have an
algorithm that's solves it.
They all began in
the same state.
You show by induction that
they all remain the same state.
Well so now we slow
down a little bit.
Each process sends a possibly
different message on each port.
But everybody sends the
same message on port k
because they're all
indistinguishable.
And then because the
way the ports match up,
everybody receives the
same message on port k.
And then they make the
same state changes.
AUDIENCE: Does this
proof imply that there's
a kernel for simplifying the
graph when you find a clique?
NANCY LYNCH: No because
if you have a graph that
consists of a clique
and then let's say,
some other stuff,
maybe the leader
could be somebody
outside the clique.
So you can't just
say because there's
a clique that you can't elect
a leader because you could
break the symmetry of the graph
with other stuff in the graph.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What assumptions do
we make to know that for each k,
they receive the same message?
NANCY LYNCH:
Because everybody is
going to send the same message
on the same numbered port,
because they're identical.
And one way the ports
can be hooked up,
and we have to tolerate all
ways they could be hooked up--
say an adversary
hooks them up-- is
that port k,
somebody's output port,
is the other end's
input port numbered k.
So then they all
receive the same message
on their port number k.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Is it actually
possible to always hook up
the boards that way.
I mean, it's like wrapped
with three vertices.
NANCY LYNCH: Well I'm
just doing it for cliques.
Yeah it is.
Yeah you could do it.
I mean you could have port
one always going clockwise,
and port two going
counterclockwise,
I mean, there's always a
way to do that in a clique.
I checked that.
So what you've just seen is
one of the very basic problems
for distributed algorithms,
which is breaking symmetry
among identical processes.
And you see that deterministic,
indistinguishable processes
just can't do it.
So we have to have
something more.
So what do you
think we could add
to make this problem solvable?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] processes.
NANCY LYNCH: I can't hear.
AUDIENCE: Probability.
Probability, OK, anything else?
So we could have the processes
actually distinguishable.
The common way in this area is
to say that each process has
an identifier.
Like, you buy a chip and it's
got some identifier burned in.
OK so you have some kind
of unique identifiers.
Or you can use randomness.
OK for unique
identifiers, you assume
everybody has some
number or some identifier
that it knows what it is.
It's built into its state, let's
say, a special state variable.
They're totally
ordered, generally.
They could be integers, or
from some totally ordered set.
When you say unique
identifiers, is
it means that different
identifiers could
appear any place in the graph.
But each identifier can
appear at most once.
You can have a huge identifier
space in a small graph.
But you're Just selecting
some identifiers
to put in the
processes in the graph.
So that's one set up.
And the other one, of
course, is using randomness.
So let's look at the
unique identifiers first.
Now the problem becomes easy.
Let's look at the clique again.
Suppose there's an
algorithm-- well, let's
construct an algorithm
that consists
of deterministic processes
with unique identifiers.
And we're going to guarantee
to elect a leader in the graph.
And moreover, it's
just going to take
one round of communication.
And it's only going to
use n squared messages.
How could that work?
Everybody in this click
has a unique identifier.
What would they do?
Send it out, right?
So you can just send
it on all your ports.
Everybody would send its
unique identifier on all
its output ports.
And then they collect the unique
identifiers from everyone else.
So everybody sees the
same set of identifiers.
And so the process with the
maximum unique identifier
knows that it's the only
one with that identifier.
And it's the biggest one.
So it can elect
itself the leader.
So all you is unique
identifiers and the ability
to exchange them reliably.
And you can elect
somebody easily.
Randomness, well,
various ways to do it.
But one idea is the processes
could just choose identifiers
randomly.
You take a sufficiently large
set of possible identifiers,
and so if they just choose
uniformly at random,
they're likely to choose
all different identifiers.
Once you have these
randomly chosen identifiers
you could use them like the
really unique identifiers.
The only thing is you might,
there's a small chance
that you'll have a duplicate.
In which case, you want to be
able to detect that and repeat
this.
So first of all, how big
the a set do you need?
Well here's an example.
Suppose that you have
the n processes choosing
at random, independently
from a space of size r.
Identifiers are the
numbers one through r.
OK and r is going
to depend on n.
It's going to be like n
squared, but it's also
going to depend on epsilon,
which is the error probability
that you're interested in.
Turns out that n squared over
2 epsilon is good enough.
OK so you have your IDs
space at least that large.
And then you can guarantee that
with probability at least 1
minus epsilon, all the
numbers that everybody chooses
are different.
It's a very easy proof.
The probability-- just look
at two particular processes--
what's the probability that
they choose the same number?
It's just 1 over r, right.
Because they're both
choosing at random.
The first one chooses something.
The probability
that the second one
chooses the same thing
is just 1 over r.
But now you can
take a union bound,
just add up the probabilities
of any pair having a duplicate.
And so you have n square
around n squared over 2 pairs.
And so multiplying 1 over
r by n squared over 2
still keeps your probability
less than or equal to epsilon,
your error probability.
So you can choose
identifiers using randomness.
With large enough space,
with very high probability,
you can get them to
be all different.
And now here's how
the algorithm works.
So you get an algorithm that
would finish in only one round,
with probability
1 minus epsilon.
But it will be correct.
And it will have
repeated rounds,
in case the first
round doesn't work.
But the expected
time is just 1 over 1
minus epsilon, not very big.
What's the algorithm?
Well processes just choose the
random IDs from the big space,
like we just said.
They exchange their Ids.
And now, everybody
can see everyone's ID,
but they also can tell
if there's a duplicate.
if the maximum is not unique.
So if the maximum is unique,
find the maximum wins.
And everyone knows that.
Otherwise you have a problem.
And you have to repeat.
And you just keep doing
that until you succeed.
So this can just
continue, but it's
likely to finish very fast,
if you have a high likelihood
of having no duplicates.
Questions about the
leader election?
So the story was, it's
impossible without something
to help you distinguish
some processes.
You can do it with
unique identifiers.
You can do with randomness.
Second problem is called
maximal independent set.
So you have a picture of
a maximal independent set
in a graph here.
Let's try this.
Yeah cursor.
So the maximal independent
set in the graph is here.
But this is something I'll
come back to a minute.
This is actually a use of
the maximal independent set
to model what happens
in a certain kind
of biological system.
What's a maximal
independence set?
So you start with a general,
undirected graph network.
And the problem is to choose
a subset of the nodes so that
they form what we call
a maximal independent .
Set let's break that down.
What does this mean?
Independent means you don't
have any two neighbors that
are both in the set.
So you don't want to get
two neighbors in the set.
Maximal means that
whatever set you choose,
you can't add any more nodes
without violating independence.
So now this should
look something
like a couple of
homework problems
that you had from the
beginning and recently.
But I'm not saying that it's
maximum independent set.
I'm not saying you have to
have the global, largest
number of nodes.
I'm just saying it has
to be a local optimum,
in the sense that you can't
add any more nodes to your set
without violating the
independence property.
Make sense?
There's two examples,
the same graph,
two different maximal
independent sets.
The green nodes, here
we have four green nodes
that are independent, not
neighbors of each other.
And they're maximal,
in that I couldn't
add any of the red
nodes into a set
without violating the
independence property.
But then over here, we have a
second maximal independent set
for the same graph.
Now we just have two nodes.
And you can't add
any of the red nodes
without violating the
independence property.
In other words, every
node is either in the MIS,
or has a neighbor in the MIS.
There's nothing else you can
do to add notes to the MIS
So the notion of maximal
independence, that make sense?
All right, so to make this
a distributed problem,
let's start out assuming we
have no unique identifier.
Actually, for this
whole problem,
we're not going to have
unique identifiers.
They're all going
to be identical.
The processes do need
one piece of information,
which is some approximation
to n, the size of the network,
the total number of vertices.
So we would like to
have these nodes somehow
cooperate to compute an MIS
of the entire network graph.
What that means is every process
should find out whether it
is in the MIS or not.
If it is, it should output n.
And if it's not,
it'll just output out.
So you don't have to
actually compute this,
like you're used
to solving problems
like this, where somebody
has to gather all
the information in one place.
Nobody gathers anything.
Everybody just has to
know whether or not
they're in the MIS.
So as you can
imagine, this is going
to be unsolvable
in certain graphs
by deterministic algorithms,
by the same kind of symmetry
breaking problems that you
saw for leader election.
So we're going to move right
to randomized algorithms
for this problem.
Some applications
of distributed MIS,
well they come up in
communication networks,
where you want to choose--
let's say you have a very
dense network of processes.
You want to choose just
a few nodes, which would
be like an overlay network.
You would choose some
nodes who could take charge
of communication that you can
communicate on this overlay
network, and then in
the end, each node
can take care of communicating
with its many neighbors.
So that's a common
sort of application.
But it also comes
up in other places.
A great example is in
developmental biology, where
a couple of years ago, there
was a paper in Science by Afek,
Alon-- there's like
eight authors on that.
But Ziv Bar-Joseph was the
lead author of this paper.
So the idea is you have a
bunch of cells in a fruit fly.
And during development,
some of those cells
are supposed to
distinguish themselves
as being what's called
sensory organ precursor cells.
The properties that you
want it that actually, you
would like a maximal independent
set of the cells to become
distinguished in this way.
So they wrote a paper about
it, got published in Science.
They basically designed a
new distributed algorithm
that closely mirrored what
happened in the fruit fly
during development.
So what I'm going to show you
is a very well-known algorithm,
a classical algorithm for MIS.
This is by Michael Luby.
Very simple algorithm,
it executes in phases.
Each phase has two realms.
So you start out with all
the nodes being active.
They're all involved.
They don't know what they're
going to end up with.
And at each phase, some
of the active nodes
are going to decide
they're in the MIS.
Some others will decide
they're out of the MIS.
And some others won't know yet.
So then you just continue
to the next phase,
with all the remaining nodes
and the edges between them.
So you're basically
going to settle
what happens with some
subset of the nodes,
and then reduce the
graph and continue.
So that's the algorithm.
So what do you do in each phase?
Here's what an active
node does at a phase.
Two rounds.
The first round, it
picks a random value
in a large space, the same
kind of idea as before.
This time it's 1 up
2 n to the fifth.
It sends that random value
to all its neighbors,
receives the values from all
its still active neighbors,
and then it just looks to see
if its value is greater than all
the values it received.
So then it's a local maximum.
It has chosen a value
that's strictly greater
than the values chosen
by all its neighbors.
So then it decides to join
the MIS and it outputs in.
But now you want to make
sure none of its neighbors--
you know that none
of its neighbors
are going to join
the MIS at round one.
Because you know this
guy's chosen value
is larger, strictly larger,
than all its neighbors.
But now you want to tell them
that they should not join.
They should be out.
So if you join the
MIS you're going
to announce that by sending
messages to all your neighbors.
And then anybody who
receives an announcement can
decide it's not going to be
in the MIS and it outputs out.
Because it knows it has a
neighbor that's in the MIS.
So if you decided in or out
at this phase, you're done.
You become inactive.
And only the
remaining active guys
continue to the next phase.
Make sense?
any questions about how
the algorithm works?
And animation.
All right so all the
nodes start out identical.
They all pick IDs.
So here's some numbers
that they pick.
So which nodes are going
to now join the MIS?
16, and the one that chose 13.
Good, so they're in the MIS.
And then at the same phase,
all of their neighbors,
those for red nodes, are going
to decide to be out of the MIS
And now you're left with
the remaining four nodes.
We don't keep going
with the same IDs.
we start over.
We want the rounds
to be independent.
So if they choose
again, they get new IDs.
And now the guy with the
12 and the guy with the 18
going to join the
MIS at this phase.
And their neighbors will
decide not to be in the MIS.
That leaves us with just one
mode, the guy who had four.
Next phase, he
chooses another ID.
But he has no neighbors
so by default,
he's bigger than
all the neighbors.
So he just joins the MIS.
So that's how this works.
Very simple algorithm,
and it actually
works to find an
MIS very quickly.
Why does this give
you independence?
How do we know that if
this ever terminates,
if everybody decides, how do
we know that we don't ever
have two neighbors that
decided to be in the MIS?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Because once
a node joins the MIS,
it broadcasts to
its neighbors that--
NANCY LYNCH: Right.
The only way you join
the MIS is if you
have the unique maximum
value in your neighborhood.
And when you do, all your
neighbors become inactive.
So you're certainly going
to have independence.
Maximality, if it
terminates, the final set
is not going to allow you
to add any more nodes.
Why?
Because a node is only
going to become inactive
if it joins the MIS, or
a neighbor joins the MIS.
And we just continue
this algorithm
until all the nodes
become inactive.
So either the node is in the
MIS or a neighbor is in the MIS.
So you can't possibly
add any more.
Yes?
So this has the
basic correctness
properties, but what
you're probably wondering,
is why is this efficient enough?
Why is it efficient?
Well we could say that with high
probability, of probability 1,
it will eventually terminate.
More quantitative, we can
state this theorem that says,
with probability at
least 1 minus 1 over n,
all the nodes decide
within four log n phases.
Since n is the
number of nodes, this
doesn't tell us that you get
probability 1 of eventually
terminating.
But we can repeat this
and get the same sort
of bound repeatedly
for successive phases.
But let's just focus on getting
probability at least 1 minus 1
over n that all nodes decide
within about four log n phases.
So let's see what
this is saying.
You have this big
complicated graph.
And in one round, for this to
be like log n behavior, what
has to happen at each phase?
You have to reduce it by
some constant fraction.
The number of nodes,
say, should go down.
So it's sort of how
the proof will go.
So we start out
with a Lemma saying,
you're choosing
these IDs at random.
You want a high probability
that they're all different.
So we have a lemma like
the one we had before.
It says, the probability
at least, we use 1 minus 1
over n squared, in each phase.
All these phases
up to four log n,
everybody's choosing a
different random value.
All the nodes choose different
values at each phase.
So this lets us
ignore the possibility
that you have repeats.
So we'll come back
to that at the end.
All right, so we're going to
pretend that in each phase,
all the random
numbers are different.
So the key idea of this is
to show that the graph has
to shrink enough at each phase.
So the way we're
going to say that is
not in terms of the
nodes, but in terms
of the number of edges.
We're going to say at
each phase, the expected
number of edges that are
live-- why is that shaking?
OK.
The expected number
of edges that
are live at the end of the
phase is at most half the number
that were live at the
beginning of the phase.
So an edge is live, if its
endpoints are still live.
So instead of talking about
reducing the number of nodes
by a constant
fraction, I'm going
to reduce the number
of remaining edges
by constant fraction
of each phase.
So this is what
I'm going to prove.
So now I've got only three
slides, but the only three
slides today that have
calculations on them.
So probably have
to pay attention,
if you want to follow
the calculations online.
So let's see why.
But the goal is clear?
We have to reduce
the number of edges
that remain by a factor of two.
So this is actually a new
proof of this algorithm's
performance.
The proof in the original
papers is pretty complicated.
This is a very
intuitive, neat proof.
So the first line
of the proof says
if you have a node that
has a neighbor that
chooses a value that's bigger
than all of its own neighbors--
so u has a neighbor w.
W chooses a value that's
bigger than all w's neighbors.
But let's say more.
Let's say it's also bigger than
all of u's other neighbors,
besides w.
So w is really big, bigger
than all w's neighbors,
bigger than all of
u's other neighbors.
If that happens, then
what happens to u?
Well we know that w is going
to decide to join the MIS.
And u is going to
definitely die,
is not going to join the MIS.
Right?
OK?
I don't want to lose
people in the first line.
Question?
Here's a picture.
Here's u.
And it has a neighbor w.
And let's say that w's chosen
value is greater than all
of w's neighbors, but
also greater than all
of u's other neighbors.
Yes?
If w has that, w is
going to join the MIS,
and u is going to
definitely not join the MIS.
It's going to decide
out in this phase.
OK so far?
AUDIENCE: Why does you need
w to have value greater
than u's neighbors?
Because if w is greater than
all of its neighbors then it's--
NANCY LYNCH: --be in the MIS
and u will not be in the MIS.
And that seems like
it ought to be enough.
But look at the next line.
Well the line after this one.
What's the probability that
w chooses a value like that?
So if it's going to be bigger
than all u's neighbors, and all
of w's neighbors,
and keeping in mind
that they are each
other's neighbors,
turns out that
there is degree u,
at most degree u plus degree
w nodes involved here.
W has to have the
biggest of all of those,
so it's going to
have the probability
1 over the number of nodes
of being the biggest one.
So it's just 1 over
the degree of u
plus the degree of
w, the probability
that w will choose
a big enough value.
But you ask, this
is pessimistic.
Why don't I just say that w
is bigger than its own values?
Because I want to
do this next step.
I want to say the probability
that node u gets killed
by one of its neighbors, any one
of its neighbors in this phase.
I can calculate that as the sum.
The probability that node
u is killed by a neighbor
is at least the sum over
all of its neighbors.
You look at all the vertices
in the neighbor set,
and you add up this fraction.
So why did I need to make that
additional assumption before?
That w is greater than
all of u's neighbors,
as well as all of
its own neighbors.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So you can
add a problem to--
NANCY LYNCH: Yeah
because otherwise these
would be overlapping events.
But this way I know they're
definitely disjoint events.
We can't have-- if we
have w and w prime,
you can't have both
of those holding
because the requirement for
w is saying that its ID is
bigger than w prime's ID.
Because you have
these disjoint events,
you can just add
the probabilities.
And you know that
the probability
that u gets killed
by some neighbor
is at least this summation.
OK so far?
So now I'm going to calculate.
But I wanted to
focus on the edges.
So let's see, this tells us a
way that a node can get killed.
But let's look at what happens
for an edge getting killed.
This is the probability
that a node is killed.
So the probability that
an edge dies at this phase
is at least the maximum
of the probability
that either of its
two endpoints die.
And let's just write
it as the average.
The probability
that an edge dies
is at least the average
of the probability
that it's two endpoints
are killed, in this way.
So for an edge, an edge is
definitely going to die,
if one of its endpoints dies.
And then the edge dies if it
dies in this particular way.
So the probability an edge dies
is at least the probability
that one of the-- half the
sum of the probabilities
that the two end points die.
It's the average probability.
Makes sense?
You might have to
read this later.
So now we can go from that to
the expected number of edges
that die.
What is that?
You just add up, over all,
the edges, the probability
that the edge dies.
The expected number
of edges that die
is at least the sum over all
of the edges of the probability
that the two endpoints die.
So you have the sum,
over all of the edges.
You add up for all the edges.
The probability that
one endpoint is killed,
and the probability the
other endpoint is killed.
So what we have is this
great big summation
involving now the kill
probabilities for vertices.
So we have the kill
probability for each vertex.
How many times does that occur?
If you have a vertex, u, it
appears once for every edge
that u is an endpoint of.
So you have the kill probability
for each node occurring exactly
it's degree number of times.
So that lets me rewrite
this in terms of vertices.
This sum is just 1/2 the
sum over all the nodes
of the probability that the node
gets killed times its degree.
So I'm calculating by
replacing the description
in terms of edges,
by description
in terms of vertices.
More or less OK so far?
So now what do I do?
Well, I know the probability
that u is killed.
I have a bound for that
up on the first line.
So I'm just going
to plug that in.
So I get 1/2 the sum
over all the nodes,
the degree of the node times
this summation that gives me
the kill probability
for that node.
And now I play
around with the sum.
I can move the degree
inside the second summation,
and I get this.
So now let's stare
at this again.
I have the sum over all
nodes of the sum over all
of its neighbors
of some expression.
But if I'm considering a
node, every note and every one
of its neighbors,
that's like considering
all the directed edges.
I look at every u, and I
look at every edge that
connects u to something else.
So I can write it as the sum
over all the directed edges
of this expression.
So I get half of
the sum over all the
directed edges of
this expression.
But we were talking
about undirected edges.
And the undirected edges
are being twice here, once
for each direction.
I can change this sum to a
sum over undirected edges.
But now I have the two
endpoints to deal with.
So I get the degree of u and
the degree of v in the numerator
because I'm looking at
it from the point of view
both of the endpoints
of each edge.
Well something
drops out, so I have
1/2 the sum over all the
undirected edges of 1.
So that's 1/2 of the
number of undirected edges.
So I don't expect you to
get every step of this,
but it's on three
slides, so you can
stare at this when you go home
and make sure the steps work.
But remember the
point of this is
to show that you reduce
the number of edges
by a factor of two, and it's
done and sort of a clever way
by counting the kill
probabilities of vertices.
So we get this, reducing
the number of edges.
And now we can just
plug that back in
to get our complexity bound
for the entire algorithm.
Remember the original theorem
you're we were to prove
is a probability bound for
deciding within log n phases.
Well you should have
a pretty good idea
of why that works
because if at each phase,
you're going to reduce
the number of edges
by around a factor
of two, then it's
going to take something
like log n phases to finish.
And I just put a proof sketch.
The number of edges that are
still alive after four log n
phases, well you divide
by 2 four log n times,
so you get down to
practically nothing.
The probability any edges are
alive at the end is very small.
So you get a small probability
the algorithm doesn't terminate
within four log n phases.
There's an extra little
term I threw in here.
You might have forgotten.
There was a term that I needed
for the small probability,
that somebody chose
duplicate IDs.
So I'm bringing them
back in at the end,
in a little union bound.
And we get our 1 over
n probability this way.
But the key idea is you
reduce the number of edges
by half at each stage.
Enough for you to look at later,
I guess to figure this out
or you have any
questions about this?
So that's the last
equations and calculation.
I'm going to go onto a new
idea, more conceptual stuff.
Familiar problem,
breadth-first spanning trees,
setting up breadth-first
paths to every node,
but we're going to study
it in our new setting.
We have a connected graph.
This time, let's suppose that
it has a distinguished vertex,
like it already has a leader.
So it has a distinguished
vertex in the graph
that's going to become
the root of the BFS tree.
And the processes don't
need any knowledge
about the graph for this one.
For the rest of the
time today and Thursday,
we'll assume the processes
have unique identifiers,
and I don't think we're
using any probabilities.
So this is just going to be
using the unique identifiers
to solve our problems.
So everybody knows its
own unique identifier.
The root has a distinguished,
generally known,
unique identifier say i0.
And the process that
has i0 knows hey,
I'm at the root of the graph.
So the set up make sense?
We might as well
assume that everybody
knows the unique identifiers
of their neighbors
because they could easily
exchange information
now, and match up who's
connected on which port
by a unique identifier.
We'll just do deterministic.
There'll be a little bit
of non-determinism here.
I'll say more about that.
But I'm not going to worry
about probabilities for this.
Well that told you
about the general setup.
What are the processes
supposed to do?
Well they're supposed to compute
a breadth-first spanning tree,
rooted at vertex v0.
The branches are
going to be directed
paths in this undirected
graph, coming from v0.
Spanning means they should
reach all the vertices.
And breadth-first means that
if a vertex is at a distance
d from v0, it will appear at
depth d in this spanning tree.
So everybody should get a
shortest path from the root.
Now how are we going to compute
this in a distributed setting?
Well now the output
of a process is just
going to be its
parent in the tree.
So we're not actually going
to compute this tree anywhere
as a whole.
Everybody's just going to
know its parent in the tree.
Questions?
Problem make sense?
So this is just an example
of a spanning tree,
breadth-first spanning tree.
This gives you shortest
paths to all of the nodes, ,
shortest in terms of
the number of hops.
So we can have a very,
very simple algorithm.
We're going to let the processes
mark themselves as they
get included in the tree.
Starts out only the first
process, i0, is marked.
So do you want to give an idea,
maybe, of how this might work?
Sketch out-- yeah?
AUDIENCE: The root will
send out to its neighbors.
And they will then
mark themselves
as the parent of
whoever they heard from.
Then they will--
NANCY LYNCH: This
is all synchronous.
So that's great.
They'll be doing this
in synchronous rounds.
So everybody will, at
the certain distance,
is going to get the message
at the right number of rounds
to mark their distance.
OK so in round one,
process i0 will
send a special
message, say search,
to all of its neighbors.
And anybody who receives
a message in round one
will mark itself,
decide i0 is its parent,
could output that i0 is
my parent, parent i0.
And then it can get
ready for the next round,
when it's supposed to
send to continue this.
So at later rounds, if you
decided you're going to send,
if you know you're supposed to
send from the previous round,
then you send a search message
to all of your neighbors.
Now the process is
sitting there and it
receives a search message.
If he's already marked, then he
should just ignore the message.
Once you're included
in the tree,
you don't care if you
get other messages,
search messages on other paths.
So you only do anything
if you're not yet marked
and you receive a message.
And in that case, then
you mark yourself.
Then you mark
yourself, and then you
choose one of your neighbors
as to be your parent.
Now because this
is synchronous, you
have several nodes that could
be sending at the same time.
So one node could be
receiving search messages
from several different
neighbors at once.
Well, it wants to choose
one of them as its parent,
doesn't matter which
one it chooses.
So it can just choose
nondeterminstically just
arbitrarily.
And then it decides that it
will send the next round.
Is the algorithm clear?
So there's, I mentioned, a
little bit of nondeterministic
here, only in that a process
can choose arbitrarily
among several possible parents.
And then we could
put in a default,
saying that it chooses the
one with the smallest ID,
if we really want to
make it deterministic.
But it's also OK to leave
distributed algorithms
nondeterministic.
And here I should
make a remark that
shows how differently
nondeterminism
is regarded in the
distributed setting,
from the way it is for
sequential algorithms.
For distributed algorithms,
there can be many options.
And maybe they're all OK.
But the algorithm is
supposed to work correctly,
no matter how you resolve
the nondeterministic choices.
So think about like
np, and the other ways
that you've seen
nondeterminism so far.
There you say you're lucky if
there is a path to a choice.
Here when you make a
nondeterministic choice,
or when the algorithm
behaves nondeterministically,
all the choices are
supposed to work.
It's like all the paths have to
come up with correct answers.
Do you have a question?
AUDIENCE: Yes, whenever
there's a sub- [INAUDIBLE],
whenever there's
a race condition,
we locally assume that
there wasn't a difference
in local computation time.
But if there is, even
in the slightest,
then they would get a parent
[INAUDIBLE] before another one,
it would still be a valid--
NANCY LYNCH: So the
synchronous model
is more abstract than that.
You don't model the
local computation time.
You're moving more toward
an asynchronous model,
where the steps can take
differing amounts of time.
Here we just assume you have
an abstract model, where
everybody does stuff
at once, in each round.
But you still have
nondeterminism
because they can all arrive
at the same round somewhere.
But it's OK.
You can pick any one
and it still works.
So it should be not hard to
see that this does give you
a BFS tree because you're
creating all the branches
synchronously.
And you're growing
one hop at each round.
It reaches all the
nodes eventually
because the graph is connected.
And everybody sends messages
once a node get marked.
It sends messages
to its neighbors.
So eventually, the
markings are going
to reach all the neighbors,
all the nodes in the graph.
So here's how you get the
example I showed before,
simple breadth-first search.
That's a search message
sent by this guy.
I put it to the
right of the edge
to indicate-- it's kind
of hard to distinguish.
But I put them on
the right of the edge
from the point of
view of the sender.
So he sends a search message.
it gets there.
This arrow just indicates
that it reached the other end.
And this guy has
chosen the sender,
which is the other direction
on the arrow, as its parent.
Now the recipient is going
to send some search messages.
So he sends four of them.
They all get to the other end.
And OK, so all these
guys now get marked.
They're included
in the BFS tree.
And now the next round,
they all send some messages.
I'm not putting in the messages
where somebody would send back
to a guy who sent to him.
But I put in all the others.
Some of them are
going to be ignored.
But you do get to a
few new nodes this way.
That's round three.
Round four, everybody sends.
And now you have all
the nodes included.
So this gives you
the spanning tree
that I showed at the
beginning of this topic.
This is not a very
complicated algorithm.
But I think you can see
that things can get worse.
And you want to argue about why
the algorithms work correctly.
So as I said before,
a popular method
of reasoning about
the algorithms
is to state invariance.
So here, suppose
I want to describe
the state of the entire
network, after some number, r,
of rounds.
what could you say about that?
What's the case after r
rounds of this algorithm?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: All nodes at
distance r from the root
have been marked.
NANCY LYNCH: All the nodes
at distance r from the root
have been marked.
In fact, only those by
round r, only the ones
with distances up through
r have been marked.
So to state the invariance, if
you want to state invariance,
I have to say what's in
the state of the processes.
So all right, what can we say?
So the process has a Boolean
that says whether or not
it's marked.
It has a place to
record a parent.
And it has someplace
where it puts information
about whether it's
supposed to send
a message at the next round.
And we also should
know its UID, so I'll
put that in another
state variable.
So here is something I
can say in invariance.
At the end of r rounds, as you
said, at the end of r rounds
exactly the processes
at distance at most r
from the source node, the
root node, are marked.
I can say a little more.
I can say a process has its
parents defined if and only
if it's marked.
So it doesn't just get market.
It also computes a
parent, and the parent
gets computed at the point
where it gets marked.
Then I should say that
the parent is correct.
So for any process that's at
distance d from the source,
if the parent is
defined, then it's
in fact the UID of a process
at distance d minus 1
from the source.
So that says it's
actually getting
a correct breadth-first tree.
It's getting the parent
on a shortest path.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do these invariants
[INAUDIBLE] for i0?
NANCY LYNCH:
Distance 0 is marked.
i0 doesn't ever-- I
see what you're saying.
i0 doesn't have a parent.
So I guess that we
should say for i
not equal to i0 in this case.
So this would be a
process other than i0.
It would have its
parent defined,
if and only if it's marked.
Well as I think
you just noticed,
the root node is marked but
it doesn't have a parent.
So it's an exception.
But this should be,
this doesn't involve i0.
So the second one, I
can fix that a bit.
Other comments, questions?
So if somebody wanted to
do a formal correctness
proof of an algorithm
like this one,
you would use these invariants.
You prove it by induction.
In fact there's
quite a few people
who use interactive theorem
provers to do proofs
like this because the algorithms
can get pretty complicated,
with a lot of variables.
So you have to do
some bookkeeping.
You keep track of
all these invariants,
and then you want to prove that
they're all true by induction.
They all hold through
an inductive step.
So you can use an
interactive theorem prover
to help you do the bookkeeping.
But even a manual proof
in a research paper
would use invariance
in this style.
OK complexity.
So the number of rounds until
everybody outputs their parent
would be the maximum
distance of any node from v0.
So we can say that's at most
the diameter of the graph.
It could be less.
It's just is the
maximum distance
from this particular node.
Message complexity?
Well how many messages are
sent in this algorithm?
So everybody is going
to send messages
only once on all of its edges.
So that means all the
edges get a message sent
in each direction just once.
So it's order of
the number of edges.
All right, so we can
play around with this.
So this algorithm just tells
everybody who his parent is.
But maybe when you're
finished, you'd
like to who your
children are as well.
For many uses of
these trees, you'd
like to have a parent be
able to talk to its children
in the tree.
So how to do that?
Well you can add a child
pointer because anybody
who gets a search message
and selects its parents
could send back a message
to that parents saying, hey,
I'm your child.
And if you get a search message,
and you decide that that's not
your parent, you can
help that guy out
by sending a message saying
you're not my parent.
In the synchronous
case, he would just
know that, if he didn't
get a parent message.
But things are going to
get more complicated.
So we'll send parents
or non parent responses
to the search messages.
Suppose we want to compute
the distances from v0,
not just to the parents are.
Well that's easy.
Everybody can just record
its distances, as well as
its parent and the mark.
And then you just include
your own distance value
in your search message.
And when somebody
receives a search message,
it sets its own distance to
the received distance plus 1.
So we can just keep track
and add one to the distance.
It's easy to augment
this algorithm
to get this extra information.
All right, now how
do the processes know
when this is all finished?
So everybody was able
to output parent.
I know who my parent is.
But how does anybody
know when the entire tree
has been produced?
Not so obvious.
So in some settings, you
might know an upper bound
on the depth of the tree.
And then you could just wait
for that number of rounds.
But what if you don't know that?
You don't know anything
about the graph.
Nobody knows.
So let's come up
with an algorithm
for process i0, the root,
to know definitively
that the tree has been
completely constructed.
Ideas?
You're creating this
by search messages.
How is i0 going to
know when its done?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Every time
you mark a node,
the node can send a
message back to its parent,
saying hi, I've been marked.
Then you can probably get
all the way back to the root.
And then the root can count
the number of-- actually,
no if the root doesn't--
NANCY LYNCH: Root doesn't
know the number of nodes.
So that's a good idea.
AUDIENCE: If you
don't have a child,
you can tell your parent
that you don't have a child.
NANCY LYNCH: That's
a good start.
Was there another?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: More
generally, you just
send a signal when you
know your sub-tree is done.
NANCY LYNCH: When you know
you're sub-tree is done,
so that means you're going
to be communicating something
up the tree.
Right, so that's the idea
that you're working toward.
So a termination
algorithm to inform i0
when the tree is
completely constructed.
So let's say that the search
messages get their responses.
So everybody knows
which nodes are their,
which neighbors are its
children, and which are not.
So suppose a node
has gotten responses
to all of its search messages,
knows who all its children are.
Now the leaves in
this tree are going
to know that they're leaves.
How do they know that?
Propagating all these search
messages, and I'm a leaf.
How do I know I'm a leaf?
AUDIENCE: You can't
have children.
NANCY LYNCH: Yeah, you send
all these search messages,
and everybody says, sorry
you're not my parent.
So you know you have no
children because of the kind
of responses you get.
So now we're going
to use what we
call a convergecast strategy.
Broadcast is sending things out.
Convergecast is fanning
in information back
to the top of the tree.
So the convergecast
would say, all right,
so the leaves would send
a message to their parents
saying they're done.
Now if I'm some node in
the middle of the tree,
how do I know I'm done?
Well it's what you said.
You know that you
can figure out when
your entire sub-tree is done.
Well first of all, you have
to know your children are.
It's kind of a
two stage process.
You have to know who
your children are,
by having received responses
to all your search messages.
And you wait to receive
done messages from all
of your actual children.
So if I'm sitting in
the middle of the tree,
and I've got done messages
from all my children,
I know my whole
sub-tree is done.
Then I can send the done
message to my parent.
Got that?
That's how convergecast works.
And when it reaches
the top, if i0
knows who its children are,
and it receives done messages
from all its children, it
knows the whole tree is done.
So it can output that the
tree construction is complete.
And it could tell
the others by sending
a message down the tree,
so they all know as well.
Questions?
AUDIENCE: Wouldn't i0
be the last one to know?
NANCY LYNCH: He'd
be the last one.
No, he'd be the first one to
know that the whole tree is
complete.
Everybody else knows when
their sub-tree is complete.
So i0 still has to now send
another message down the tree
to tell everyone else the
entire tree is complete.
Is there another question?
All right so this
isn't showing that.
This is just showing done
messages, which are actually
going in the opposite
direction from these edges,
going up the tree.
But you can just see
how they propagate up
until the roots says done.
No big deal.
Complexity for termination.
Well it just takes at most
diameter rounds and n messages
for this done information
to come up to the top,
once the tree
actually is finished.
Because now you're
just sending messages
on the paths in this
tree, which are only,
at most, diameter in length.
And this is just the process
i0 can tell everybody else.
It doesn't take
very long either.
Applications, well suppose you
construct a tree like this.
And process i0 now wants
to use it to communicate.
It wants to send a
whole batch of messages
to all the other nodes.
It can just send
them now on the tree.
It's an easy way to
make sure messages reach
everybody else in the network.
Just send them on the edges
of the breadth-first spanning
tree.
So now the messages,
each individual message
takes at most n
message instances
along the edges of the
tree, because you only have
to traverse the tree edges.
No more dependence on the total
number of edges in the network.
And in fact, you can
save time by pipelining
a series of messages.
So you can send them one
round after the other.
The other way, suppose you want
to compute something globally.
Suppose everybody starts
with some initial value.
And process i0 is going
to try to determine
the value of some function
of everybody's initial value,
like the minimum or maximum
or the sum or anything.
Well you can do this
while convergecasting
on an already built BFS tree.
So everybody can just send
their information up the tree,
and i0 can collect it all.
In general, you
can accumulate, you
can do data aggregation as you
go up the paths of the tree.
So the message size
doesn't blow up.
So if you want, for example,
the sum of everybody's values,
everybody just sends their
values up in a convergecast.
And each node computes
the sum of all the values
in its sub-tree.
So this is pretty efficient.
Make sense?
I'm going to skip this.
But you could do leader
election in a general graph,
If you don't have
a leader, already,
i0 by having everybody
run a breadth-first search
in parallel.
But we'll skip that.
Because I just wanted to
have a couple of minutes
to start the last topic, and
we'll pick it up next time.
So it's the obvious extension.
Instead of just
breadth-first search trees,
let's put weights
on the edges and try
to compute shortest paths trees
in terms of the total weight
of the path.
So we're going to add weights.
It's an undirected graph.
So it's just a weight
for each undirected edge.
I'll still have a starting
node, vertex v0 with process i0.
Still have unique identifiers.
And I'll assume the processes
know who their neighbors are.
And they know the
weights of the incident
edges, their adjacent edges.
But otherwise they
don't need to know
anything else about the graph.
So again, this is
a familiar problem.
But we're looking at it
in a very different way,
by distributing it.
so the processes are supposed to
compute a shortest paths tree,
in the sense that
everybody should
output its parent in the tree.
And let's say they output
the distance as well,
the weighted distance
from the root node.
So this is called
Bellman-Ford's algorithm.
Again it's got the same name
in the distributed setting.
The Bellman-Ford
shortest paths algorithm.
So everybody is keeping
track of their current best
distance that they
know, and their parent.
And they know their
unique identifier.
And here's how the
algorithm works.
This will look
familiar from when
you had Bellman-Ford earlier.
At every round,
everybody is going
to send its distance
to its neighbors.
Instead of just sending
a search message,
now it will send its actual
distance information.
And you receive the messages
from your neighbors.
And now you do a relaxation
step, as you've seen before.
You look at the current
distance you have.
And you see if you've
gotten a new distance
from a neighbor, such that if
you add the new distance you
receive to the weight of
the edge between yourself
and that neighbor, you
get something better
than what you had before.
If you get that, then you're
going to improve your distance.
And if you improve
your distance,
then you're going
to reset your parent
to the sender of this new,
better distance information.
So does this
algorithm make sense?
It's like what you saw before.
But there's no running
through all the nodes.
Each node is doing
its own thing.
It's waiting to get better
distance information
and re-computing.
And then it's going to
be sending out its better
information at the next round.
Question?
So this is kind of a jump
in the way of thinking.
All right, so now I'm just
going to end basically
with an animation that'll
show you the kinds of things
that happen here.
All right so you start
out with the initial node.
And what's recorded in the
circle is the best distances.
The rest of these, the best
distance they know is infinity.
So I didn't write that.
So this guy knows 0 After one
round, he sent two messages.
The best distance each
of these guys knows
is just the weight of the
edge between v0 and itself.
So this guy's now estimating
it's distance at 16
and this guy at 1.
16 is not very good because it's
actually very roundabout routes
that can get there.
But it's going to take us some
time to make that adjustment.
After two rounds, everybody
is sending their distance
information.
But now we get a
correction here.
This used to say 16.
But now we have a
two hop path that
gives you a better distance.
So you get the 1 plus the 14.
So he's going to here,
about the distance of 15
as a result of what 1 sends.
And some new guys get their
distance is calculated
And then after three rounds, it
gets a little bit complicated.
So maybe I'm just going to
flip through it quickly and let
you study later.
But you see that you keep
getting improvements,
as you perform relaxation steps.
As information gets to
somebody by better paths that
happen to have
more hops, they're
going to be reducing
their estimates.
I'm going to flip, and you
see that this guy's estimate
is going down.
And in the end, after
eight rounds of this,
you end up with a
very roundabout path
that actually gives this
guy a much better estimate.
So you can see how that works.
So the claim is that
eventually, every process
will have its distance being
a correct minimum weight
of the path, and its
parent will be correct.
I think maybe this is
a good place to stop.
We'll pick up with this
algorithm and its analysis.
Most of next time
is going to be spent
on asynchronous
algorithms, which
is a whole other
level of complication.
So I'll see you on Thursday.